le bricolage avant son divorce ce
n'était pas trop le truc de valérie mais
cette maman de deux enfants a dû s'y
mettre pour refaire les murs de son
salon
l'artisan qu'elle a consultés lui aurait
pris 1900 euros
à ce prix là valérie hains préféré
retrousser ses manches
alors ici j'ai fait les murs cette pièce
en fait il y avait une grande fissure
bas on la voit plus du tout un coup de
peinture et puis voilà on a l'impression
qu'il est tout neuf mais valérie n'en a
pas fini avec les travaux aujourd'hui
elle doit résoudre un problème de visa
be à chaque fois je suis assis sur mon
canapé enfin les mets voisin d'en face
vois ce que je fais ca me gêne un petit
peu donc je vous mettais dit je vais
mettre un rideau pour couper
la vue n'est des mamans modernes
maintenant et oui la caisse à outil
n'est plus un domaine exclusivement
réservé aux hommes
aujourd'hui un client sur deux qui
rentre dans un magasin de bricolage est
une femme carrelage électricité
plomberie papier peint elles veulent
savoir tout faire et tout seul même si
c'est parfois un peu dur à avaler c'est
juste bon à lévis
j'appelle pas ça du bricolage
ta femme je pense que lui aussi montré
ce qu'elle est capable de faire des
trois paires se sont aperçus ça
avec fil sans fil j'ai également la scie
sauteuse dans ce marché colossal estimé
à 22 milliards d'euros on trouve
désormais des tournevis rose des
sacoches résolument féminine et de
l'outillage spécialement conçu pour
madame
il existe même des cours de bricolage
interdit aux hommes
alors qui sont ces nouvelles bricoleuse
du dimanche comment les industriels
font-ils pour s'adapter à la demande
combien ça coûte l'hebdo a mis le bleu
de travail
trouvons valérie qui doit installer des
rideaux chez elle problème elle n'a
jamais utilisé une perceuse de sa vie
rendez vous dans un magasin spécialisé
pour un cours un peu particulier
bonjour à vous au cours de fixation je
fixe une trêve ici que des femmes des
débutantes confronté aux mêmes soucis
c'est jamais de cette perceuse lecerf
d'une perceuse un harry ici on paye 30
euros pour apprendre le b à ba du
bricolage
le tout dans une ambiance très salon de
thé au mur tout rose
celle qui est derrière ce concept c'est
elle
marie david o il ya six mois elle a
quitté son emploi pour créer sa propre
enseigne des cours mixtes de bricolage
ça existait déjà mais les femmes en ont
souvent marc d'essuyer les railleries
des hommes
d'où l'idée de créer ce nouveau concept
c'est comme si on avancions ensemble et
qu'on soient pas écrasés par les
connaissances des uns et des autres
rabaissée de ce moteur rien compris
c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut faire
enfin cours de filles puis c'est plus
convivial mais si on n'a pas de tabou
après la théorie place à la pratique et
quand on est novice est plus compliqué
que ça en a l'air
pour la plupart d'entre elles c'est un
peu un baptême du feu au micro ici on
peut apprendre à peindre son salon poser
le carrelage de sa salle de bain même
réparer un lavabo
l'intérêt c'est de pouvoir faire des
erreurs qu'il ne faut surtout pas
répéter chez soi
brecko à cette chère de france a fait un
gros budget belle économiser un futur
mettis qu'elle serait plus une heure et
demie plus tard les tringles à rideaux
donc plus de secret pour nos apprentis
bricoleuse je pense que ce qu'on fera
après les cours on passe en boutique et
là aussi le parti pris est claire je
bricole sans mon homme sans le son pour
vous en sortir sans mal les bricolos
macho en prennent pour leur grade et
pour ranger ses outils marie a pensé à
tout on a des trous se trompent briques
et bleu et pareil pour la chaussée les
sifflets et 17
à donner une vie plutôt joli
mode à tout l'univers du collège parce
que c'est ce que les clientes
recherchent les femmes sont l'avenir du
bricolage et ça même les grandes
enseignes l'ont bien compris
cette campagne publicitaire a fait
décoller les ventes du numéro deux du
bricolage et c'est joël bean et qui a
piloté le projet
la mission que son agence de pub élus
ont accepté changer d'image de cette
enseigne de façon radicale et ça n'était
pas gagné d'avancé
comme avec du retard par rapport à son
concurrent principal en terme d'image de
modernité d'accessibilité pour nous
notre idée ça a été de créer un
électrochoc et de d'aller carrément sur
la population féminine
pari réussi la campagne a tellement bien
marché que 35 pub ont été tournées et ce
sont les humoristes florence foresti et
le réalisateur de cinéma patrice leconte
qui ont écrit les dialogues c'est toi
qui as fait ça tout seul à la clé pour
cette agence un contrat de près de 10
millions d'euros
si c'est nous
il va falloir s'y faire dans les
magasins de bricolage les femmes sont
aujourd'hui omniprésentes et pour les
vendeurs de ce grand magasin parisien
elles sont même dans le collimateur la
cible le plan d'action c'est la
clientèle féminine
nous allons nous focaliser sur la
clientèle femmes 57 % de nos clients
sont des femmes
la cliente idéale pour un vendeur c'est
la novice celles qui n'y connait rien et
qui doit s'équiper entièrement ces cas
là j'ai une perceuse visseuse mais
pourquoi pas apprendre avec ça un
coffret tournevis un coffret de marteau
un coffret dont notamment complet une
boîte à outils ainsi de suite donc sans
oublier la petite annonce au micro pour
être sûr que toutes les clientes passe
bien par la case bricolage du stock
derrière cher cliente
nos conseillers sont à votre disposition
pour vous aider dans votre choix en
outillage vos achats vous les offrir
n'hésitez pas surtout le conseiller sont
là avec 1 kg 10 pendant ce temps michel
le responsable boîte à outils et son
assistant e sont en train de mettre en
place un véritable piège à bricoleuse
des anciennes sacoche l'électricien
d'edf relooké en sac à main c'est vrai
que quand on voit la différence est
qu'on est une femme
c'est quand même plus sympa d'avoir ça
que ça ça ça vaut dans les 30 euros mais
bon ça donne pas envie de faire du
bricolage
la petite sacoche de couleur coûte trois
fois plus cher et sans les outils et
pourtant elle part comme des petits
pains
du coup ce grand magasin a mis de la
couleur à tous ces produits gants m de
menuisier et même davis aus des
visseuses
miser de plus en plus sur la femme c'est
aussi le choix qu'ont fait les grands
industriels du bricolage
nous sommes dans la banlieue lyonnaise
au siège d'un spécialiste du petit
outillage
ici on fabrique des outils depuis un
siècle mais pour lancer sa dernière
ponceuse c'est aux femmes que cette
marque a demandé leur avis on leur
demande tout ce qu elle tout ce qu'elle
aimerait avoir dans une ponceuse facile
à utiliser compact la taille facile à
tenir en main
la firme a mis un an pour mettre au
point sa petite pause à main une bonne
demi-douzaine de prototype n'a pas
survécu on redoute etc est des
utilisatrices s'ils étaient un peu large
celle ci était un peu trop haute et
allemand depuis deux ans l'entreprise a
même créé une gamme spécialement conçu
pour séduire les femmes perceuses scies
yeuse visseuse leur point commun
légèreté ergonomie facilité
d'utilisation c'est devenu le numéro un
des ventes
ce qui séduit les bricoleuses ce sont
ces pictogrammes révolutionnaire de
petits dessins de toutes les couleurs
qui certes à régler la machine décaper
un meuble ou penser son parquet tout le
monde arriverait à la faire marcher
quand on part là c'est vrai à une cible
féminine
on rentre par l'application rendent par
la simplicité en vente par toutes les
tâches possibles avec cet outil
selon leurs prévisions 30 à 40 % des
futurs acheteurs de cette multi penseuse
seront des femmes
retour chez valérie qui doit maintenant
poser sa fameuse tringle à rideaux pour
les fixations elle a dépensé 20 euros
mais elle a littéralement craqué pour
cette perceuse semi professionnel à 160
euros
maintenant sérieuse grâce à son cours de
bricolage elle ne s'est pas trompé dans
les mesures savard vivent dangereusement
mais c'est le caisson de son volet
roulant qui lui pose problème
ces vies sont beaucoup trop grande
heureusement idéal au système d ça c'est
fait ce mérite un trou valérie aura
perdu deux heures pour mettre ses
rideaux mais elle aura économisé 150
euros c'est ce que l'installateur d'un
grand magasin lui aurait demandé ça y
est ils sont installés
gt c'est pas évident je suis content en
héros fini d'avoir réussi à finir tout
seul que les hommes se préparent les
femmes apprennent vite et elles pourront
bientôt se passer de leurs services